at a thousand people have been pulled
out from this big review You've Done but
how many are there outside of that
thousand such as the case we've had
today that you know are going through
the justice system that we might see
coming out in the coming weeks and
months
so I mean looking at this of just the
next few weeks ahead
um
uh most most weeks there's two or three
officers going to court for criminal
cases which tends to be a a mix of
sort of
dishonesty
violence and sort of violence against
women and girls type offenses to give
you sexual offenses Etc so there's
probably two or three uh
two or three a week that are sort of
appearing at court